[Aplausos]
[Música]
japón es uno de esos países que
sorprende por los cuatro costados y
dentro de todas las cosas que nos
sorprenden una de las que más nos puede
llamar la atención es precisamente la
política queridos amigos amigas desde
que cayera el imperio del japón en 1945
este país ha tenido aproximadamente unos
35 primeros ministros esto es cerca de
un primer ministro cada dos años y no no
es que el mandato sea más corto y el
mandato ordinario es de cuatro años lo
que ocurre es que japón cambia más de
primer ministro que el manchester united
entre nador durante la última década o
el chelsea que tampoco se queda atrás
pese a ello otra característica
fundamental de la política japonesa es
precisamente su estabilidad
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea desde la
llegada de la democracia a japón a
finales de los años 50 técnicamente solo
gobernando un partido político el
liberal democrático u organizaciones de
su órbita en todo este tiempo solo
podemos encontrar un breve paréntesis de
dos años en los que llegó al poder un
gobierno opositor y no evidentemente
japón no es una dictadura en la práctica
es algo así como una democracia que
funciona a partir de los órganos más o
menos democráticos de su principal
partido político no me digáis que no es
un sistema curioso el caso es que de
esta forma en el país del sol naciente
los rifirrafes políticos se libran sobre
todo en los pasillos y en los despachos
lo que ha hecho que la política nipona
se convierta en todo un rompecabezas de
idas y venidas de inmisiones elecciones
anticipadas y mociones de censura vamos
que no es precisamente aburrida lo que
daría de sí un visual política pones
[Música]
de hecho el protagonista de este vídeo
el actual primer ministro fue mío
kishida llegó al poder en octubre del
2021 y lo hizo debido a la dimisión de
su predecesor yo sí he de suba después
de estar tan solo un año en el cargo no
sé quizás cuando ves este vídeo el bueno
de ti si está se haya historia que sabe
por eso para estar actualizados y si os
gusta lo que hacemos nada mejor que
apuntaros a la comunidad de visual
política en patrón recibiréis boletines
contenido exclusivo merchandising
también exclusivo y muchas más cosas que
estamos preparando además nos ayudaréis
a seguir creciendo por ejemplo la
llegada de visual económica ha tenido
mucho pero que mucho que ver con vuestro
apoyo en pater por si queréis echarle un
vistazo os dejo un enlace en la
descripción y por supuesto muchísimas
gracias a todos los que nos apoyáis mes
tras mes y también como no a todos los
que estáis ahí al otro lado de la
pantalla vídeo tras vídeo pero no nos
desviemos el caso es que el nuevo
mandamás del país del sol naciente es un
personaje bastante diferente a lo que
hemos visto en japón durante la última
década y en cierto modo muy diferente
también al nuevo presidente de corea del
sur del que ya os hemos hablado
recientemente aquí en visual político y
lo son tanto en lo que respecta a la
forma como al fondo y es que veréis al
contrario del nuevo presidente coreano
jones porque es todo un outsider de la
política suicida es un viejo conocido
[Música]
hablamos de un político con mucha
experiencia que es miembro de la cámara
de representantes desde 1993 y que a lo
largo de los años ha sido ministro de
estado para los asuntos de okinawa y los
territorios del norte ministro de
defensa y ministro de asuntos exteriores
con shinzo abe a pesar de ello lo que se
espera de kishida es un importante giro
de timón respecto a las políticas de ave
dentro de japón y un cierto continuismo
en el caso de la política exterior que
eso sí con mucho más gasto en defensa
porque según se dice japón está de
vuelta en el tablero de las grandes
potencias mundiales
amigos amigas a nivel local quisiera se
ha propuesto entre otras muchas cosas
congelar el plan de transformación
económica conocido como ameno mix ni más
ni menos que para reinventar el propio
capitalismo el nuevo primer ministro
quiere crear algo así como una especie
de economía de mercado a la japonesa
queréis saber más sobre qué supone todo
esto y también qué planes tiene este
nuevo líder sobre cuestiones tan
importantes como las relaciones con
china o los eeuu pues si os parece
empecemos por la política exterior
atentos
[Música]
i
el despertar de un gigante dormido
durante su gobierno una de las
obsesiones de shinzo abe el primer
ministro japonés que más años han estado
en el cargo fue devolver a japón
precisamente a la escena internacional
para lograrlo entre otras medidas el
gobierno nipón comenzó a tener posturas
cada vez más duras hacia china y corea
del norte se erigió en protector de
aliados como taiwán y también lideró el
acuerdo de libre comercio transpacífico
hoy el club comercial más de moda en
todo el mundo tras la salida de eeuu
protagonizada por donald trump en otras
palabras que hemos empezado a ver a un
japón inusualmente activo en la política
internacional y no sólo eso shinzo abe
también abogó por incrementar la fuerza
militar del país
es algo que ya os hemos contado en
diferentes ocasiones bajo el impulso de
haber el gobierno japonés quiso cambiar
la constitución para poner punto y final
a su artículo 9 que establece que japón
es un país fundamentalmente pacifista
algo que ha limitado el alcance y la
financiación de sus fuerzas de
autodefensa
aspirando sinceramente a una paz
internacional basada en la justicia y el
orden el pueblo japonés renuncia para
siempre a la guerra como derecho
soberano de la nación ya la amenaza o al
uso de la fuerza como medio de solución
en disputas internacionales no se
mantendrán en los sucesivos fuerzas de
tierra mar o aire como tampoco otro
potencial bélico el derecho de
beligerancia del estado no será
reconocido artículo 9 de la constitución
de japón pues bien ahora asumió kishida
no sólo quiere seguir adelante con esta
reforma constitucional sino que quiere
ir mucho más allá y aprobar un ambicioso
plan para mejorar las capacidades
militares del país del sol naciente
y de hecho esto es exactamente lo que
están pidiendo los mismos círculos de su
partido que lo auparon al liderazgo el
gobernante pd de japón pide al gobierno
que duplique el presupuesto de defensa
hablamos de que japón poco a poco se
aproxime e incluso supere el 2% del pib
en gasto militar para que os hagáis una
idea esto llevaría el presupuesto
militar de este país hasta el entorno de
los 100.000 millones de dólares
supondría un esfuerzo adicional de entre
50 y 60 mil millones de dólares cada año
entre 240 y 300 mil millones de dólares
de nuevo gasto en un periodo de tan sólo
5 años os imagináis todo lo que podrían
comprar con semejante cantidad de dinero
evidentemente esto haría de japón toda
una superpotencia y lo convertiría en el
tercer país del mundo con mayor
presupuesto militar es por así decirlo
el sueño dorado de los eeuu de américa
otra superpotencia amiga en indochina
dispuesta a rivalizar de tú a tú con el
gigante asiático y el caso es que ahora
la guerra de ucrania ha marcado todo un
punto de inflexión el gobierno de
kishida ha pisado el acelerador para
intentar aprovechar la actual coyuntura
como si fuera una especie de turbo para
su nueva política y si también esta ave
de por medio
vélez de japón incluye el ex primer
ministro ave en la campaña para la
reforma constitucional corriendo el
riesgo de una reacción de la oposición y
la pregunta es pero qué demonios tiene
que ver la guerra de ucrania con todo
esto
pues os lo hemos dicho en varias
ocasiones amigos amigas la invasión rusa
ha supuesto un antes y un después ya
nadie se fía de los tiranos que tengan
por vecinos y de hecho tampoco lo
olvidéis japón mantiene una disputa
territorial con la misma rusia desde la
segunda guerra mundial por las islas
kuriles con crítica a la decisión de
rusia de poner fin a las conversaciones
de paz sobre las disputadas islas
kuriles por las sanciones
japón dice que las islas en disputa
están ocupadas ilegalmente por rusia
japón describe cuatro islas cuya
propiedad disputa con moscú como
ocupadas ilegalmente por rusia en la
última versión de un informe diplomático
así que ya lo veis poco a poco japón
está adquiriendo un rol cada vez más
importante y contundente en la política
de asia-pacífico claro que este no es el
único aspecto en el que se espera que el
nuevo líder japonés siga los mismos
pasos de sus antecesores quisiera
también es un firme defensor de
reposicionar a japón como el principal
actor regional en materia comercial ya
os hemos hablado de su liderazgo sobre
el gpp y sobre todo de estrechar aún los
lazos con los eeuu de américa con todo
amigos el principal reto o la principal
meta según como se mire y está mucho
pero que mucho más cerca y no por una
vez no estamos hablando de china sino de
corea del sur y si ya son
tradicionalmente malas las relaciones
entre estos dos países durante el tiempo
en el que coincidieron en el cargo
shinzo abe y mucho las cosas llegaron a
un punto mucho peor
[Música]
las provocaciones por un lado y la
intransigencia por otro y viceversa
hicieron que la pelea pareciera algo
casi interminable sin embargo ahora eso
podría estar a punto de cambiar atentos
a estos titulares corea del sur decidió
oficialmente unirse al cpp para
fortalecer la cadena de suministros y un
dice que valorará positivamente unirse
al quad si le invitan y ojo porque
aunque esto pueda parecer algo menor lo
cierto es que puede ser el comienzo de
un cambio titánico en la región como ya
os hemos dicho japón lidera el acuerdo
comercial cpp y también es miembro del
quad una especie de alianza o de
asociación militar entre eeuu australia
india y japón pues bien os imagináis lo
que supondría que de una vez por todas
corea y japón dejaron atrás sus viejas
peleas y estrecharán de una vez por
todas su relación estamos hablando de
dos colosos económicos y militares
hablamos de dos de los países más ricos
y tecnológicamente avanzados de todo el
mundo con un pib combinado de casi 7
millones de dólares y un presupuesto
militar conjunto que debe cumplirse las
aspiraciones del actual gobierno de
tokio podría llegar a oscilar entre los
110 y los 150 mil millones de dólares
cada año y podéis creerme cuando os digo
que pocas cosas gustarían más en
washington
porque amigos si tenemos en cuenta las
características de los ejércitos sus
compromisos y su dimensión en términos
de tropas hablamos de un presupuesto que
podría ser más que suficiente para
rivalizar con la mismísima república
popular china xi a ver el país de
siguiente y seguiría gastando mucho más
unos trescientos mil millones cada año
pero sus fuerzas armadas también tienen
muchos más salarios que pagar para
mantener un despliegue a lo largo y
ancho de todas las fronteras del país
por ejemplo se calcula que desde el año
2008 el aumento del coste de personal ha
devorado más de la mitad de los aumentos
del presupuesto militar chino así que en
términos de capacidad de inversión real
la balanza podría inclinarse en favor de
esa hipotética alianza nipona coreana
una alianza capaz por sí mismo de actuar
como contrapeso a todas las dictaduras
de la región no digamos ya si encima
tenemos en cuenta a eeuu australia y al
resto de sus aliados hablamos de un
cambio potencialmente tectónico claro
que también hablamos de dos países que
se llevan como el perro y el gato no
será una tarea nada pero que nada
sencilla pero sea como sea el nuevo
presidente surcoreano aboga por
estrechar estos lazos y por ahora aquí
sí está bueno digamos que el primer
ministro japonesa empezó a captar la
enorme oportunidad que esto supone
dice que la cooperación con corea del
sur se necesita más que nunca pero un
momento amigos porque esta no es toda la
historia junto a la política exterior el
otro gran objetivo político de kishida
pasa por la economía ni más ni menos que
por reinventar el capitalismo japonés
atentos
[Música]
un giro a la izquierda
xy da lo tiene muy claro quiere marcar
un antes y un después en la economía
nipona y lo quiere hacer según él
desarrollando una especie de capitalismo
a la japonesa y qué demonios significa
esto pues básicamente pasa por aplicar
políticas ultra expansivas del gasto
público y promover una mayor
redistribución de la riqueza si lo
siento en esencia son las mismas recetas
keynesianas de toda la vida que en japón
llevan aplicando desde hace ya décadas
pero ahora este líder adquirir un paso
más allá y la pregunta es por donde ha
empezado pues fijaos la dieta de japón
aprueba un presupuesto récord de 107,6
millones de yenes para 2022 el
parlamento de japón aprobó el martes un
presupuesto récord de 107,6 millones de
yenes unos 900 mil millones de dólares
para el año fiscal 2000 22 con el
objetivo de financiar medidas contra el
coronavirus así como el aumento de los
costes de seguridad social y la defensa
nacional el primer ministro quisiera de
japon desvela un paquete de estímulos de
490 mil millones de dólares para que os
hagáis una idea solo el plan de estímulo
presentado por ki sida representa más
del 65 por ciento de todo el presupuesto
del plan de recuperación post cobit de
la unión europea claro que japón tiene
tres veces y media menos población que
el club comunitario
a firmar cheques aquí si la no le va a
ganar nadie no me digáis que eso no es
pisar fuerte pero si este enorme aumento
del gasto público ya resulta llamativo
lo más importante viene quizás al ver
dónde quiere gastar kishida todo ese
dinero y todavía más importante como
busca financiarlo
la clave el punto diferencial entre x
ida y sus predecesores veis que en lugar
de seguir apostando por las reformas
económicas orientadas al crecimiento en
este caso apuesta por llevar a cabo una
enorme campaña de redistribución de la
riqueza por ejemplo quisiera quiero
incrementar los impuestos a las grandes
empresas ya las rentas más altas que
seguir tirando del banco central para
seguir emitiendo más y más deuda pública
la cual se sitúa ya en el 253 por ciento
del pib gracias precisamente al enorme
apoyo que el gobierno obtiene del banco
central y de los enormes ahorros de las
familias japonesas
[Música]
de hecho esto es precisamente lo que ha
provocado la última crisis del yen
japonés fijaos 22 de abril de 2022 japón
celebró en su día un yen barato ahora la
peor caída de la moneda en 20 años está
causando un pánico generalizado
28 de abril de 2022 el banco de japón
acentúa la caída del yen al redoblar su
política ultra relajada pues bien el
caso es que con todo ese dinero el
primer ministro ha prometido apoyo
financiero directo para los hogares con
hijos para los trabajadores a tiempo
completo y temporales y también para las
pequeñas y medianas empresas el problema
de todas estas cosas es que nunca
parecen funcionar pero oye ahí está el
bueno de equidad para intentar demostrar
todo lo contrario lo conseguirá
[Música]
el caso es que esto no es todo la otra
parte de esta especie de nuevo
capitalismo la japonesa van a poner de
vosotros el nombre que queráis y si os
parece no decís que pensáis en los
comentarios tiene que ver con esta
visita pide aumentos salariales
agresivos para impulsar la
redistribución de la riqueza el primer
ministro quisiera de japon planta un
panel insignia para analizar la
redistribución de la riqueza la
justificación para perseguir una mayor
redistribución y presionar para que las
empresas paguen salarios más altos es
que según éste el primer ministro esto
elevará la demanda de consumo y con ello
la producción y la inflación vamos lo
que se suele decir siempre el caso es
que para conseguirlo lo primero que está
haciendo por un lado es subir el salario
mínimo las pensiones y la cobertura
médica para los trabajadores y por otro
promover aumentos salariales en las
empresas a cambio de introducir ciertas
desgravaciones fiscales
[Música]
el problema es que por lo general las
empresas japonesas tienen tasas de
rentabilidad más reducidas que sus
comparables internacionales y también
que el pp por hora trabajada es cerca de
un 30% inferior a la media del g7 y casi
un 40% más bajo que el eeuu es decir que
japón no van sobrados de productividad
este es fundamentalmente el motivo por
el que no se pagan salarios por ahora
más elevados y también lo que explica
que el salario medio mensual apenas se
ha incrementado en 8 dólares y medio
durante los últimos nueve años y si esto
también tiene mucho que ver a su vez con
que la riqueza neta de los japoneses
venga cayendo con fuerza para todos los
deciles excepto para el 10% más rico de
la población que la verdad tampoco es
que han experimentado ningún tipo de
euforia
[Música]
además la subida del impuesto a las
ganancias de capital ya los dividendos
que ha planteado este primer ministro
corre el riesgo de desincentivar la
inversión lo que podría resultar en un
resultado directamente contrapuesto al
esperado sea como sea de momento esta
especie de nuevo capitalismo a la
japonesa a este nuevo capitalismo y
felicidad fumio no habéis kishidan o
mick o como demonios quieran que lo
llamen genera muchas más preguntas que
respuestas de hecho bueno algunas de las
medidas anunciadas resultan tan
ridículas como es para el regalo de
cinco mil yenes para jubilados
probablemente no produzca sonrisas la
coalición gobernante está considerando
otorgar un pago único a las personas
mayores para ayudarlos a salir adelante
de la pandemia pero es poco probable que
la cifra que se propone cinco mil yenes
42 dólares haga sonreír a muchos he
hecho muchas personas podrían considerar
la cantidad como un insulto pero bueno
ya lo veis este es el plan del nuevo
líder japonés por un lado incrementar el
peso político internacional del país del
sol naciente aumentar el gasto militar y
mejorar sus lazos con eeuu y corea del
sur por otro lado buscado para un más la
economía japonesa con incrementos
enormes de la masa monetaria estímulos
públicos deuda e inflación hay quien
podría denominarlo como una de cal y
otra en cualquier caso su margen de
actuación podría ser más bien reducido y
también estaba por ver cuánto logra
durar en el cargo no olvidéis que japón
cambia de primeros ministros casi tanto
como el manchester united de
entrenadores pero ahora llegados hasta
aquí turno para ti se convertirá japón
en un actor clave en asia pacifico qué
te parece el plan del nuevo primer
ministro teniendo en cuenta el vídeo que
hicimos sobre el nuevo presidente de
corea del sur y los dejo la descripción
a qué país crees que le irá mejor
dejadnos por aquí abajo todos vuestros
comentarios y si este vídeo se resulta
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like suscribiros a visual politics si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]